[Music]
and in the next sort of 30 minute the
three of us are going to talk about how
to use Python and machine learning to
analyze the data I've obtained from
mechanical ventilator of critically
newborn infants and who is the three of
us so my name is Gustav Pataki I'm one
of the neonatal consultants in Cambridge
Berkeley SiC neonates day and night and
on top of my job I'm also interested in
my narrator ventilation and python and
started to use Python a couple years ago
to look at data obtained from
ventilators now Ian I don't need to
introduce his valve his one of the
cofounders of pirate London and all of
the organizers of this meeting
he's also an experienced very
experienced Python programmer and
machine learning consultant and author
of this book Giles is a bio footage and
turned to Python programmer and was also
a member of the review committee for
this meeting and and and we have started
this collaboration more than half a year
ago after ficon UK and present some of
the progress and invited to London in
January and this is a kind of follow up
presentation on that and first of all
why do some newborn babies still in in
the tray require mechanical ventilation
and the reason for that is mostly
prematurity they are there's nothing
wrong with them they are born with
premature lungs premature muscle through
virtual brain and they won't be able to
breed enough to support gas exchange and
life without ventilator support in
addition some babies who are born
full-term they can still require
mechanical ventilation for some time
because of an infection birth depression
or a condition which requires surgery
and anesthesia so as a big new unit in
Cambridge we ventilate approximately
1500 ventilator days a year which is
like one patient ventilated for one day
is one ventilator day so we entered a
lot similarly to other big neonatal
units and ventilation is also an
important part of adult and and
pediatric intensive care now there are
two different ventilators one of them is
from from the 80s and the otherwise the
one which we are currently using and and
if you compare them there is a big
difference and the big difference is
that in the eighties ventilators used to
be primary mechanical devices sometimes
they didn't even have electricity they
were completely gas driven and and what
they do they just created positive
pressure inflate the lung in a way set
by the clinician had no interaction
whatsoever with the patient's own
breeding effort and today ventilators
still have got their mechanical parts
but they are primary computers and
because of their computers their
powerful computers they are creating
beneficial and harmful interactions both
with the patient's own breeding efforts
because the other things I would like to
mention is that we very dearly sedate
and muscle like babies to a point that
they don't breathe at all
this is not what modernism s indoors and
because of that because we are dealing
with two pumps during mechanical
ventilation most of the time an active
process the spontaneous breathing done
by the patient and mechanical
ventilation which is positive pressure
ventilation done by the mechanical
ventilator
there is always it's always a
combination of our superimposition
actually of these two pumps creating
complex interactions which are still
poorly understood and one of the reasons
why why it's poorly understood is
because in the past this ventilator data
which these moderate ventilators provide
haven't been download it hasn't been
analyzed the screens are looked at by
the by the clinician but apart from
individual grabs there has been a no
systematic analyzes of of this kind of
waveforms so what you can see on on this
waveform is on the left side what you
see is that well air only flows if there
is a pressure difference so what the
ventilator does in in this case which is
then a baby who is not breathing at all
on the left side this creates positive
pressure that results in a positive flow
it goes into the patient that's the
inspiration give them inflation
even by the ventilator and then that
definition release then there is an
expiration so the flow goes down - air
comes out of the lung spontaneously so
this creates a volume which is then the
breath so it's very easy and simple to
recognize this is there is no patient
contribution but once there is a patient
contribution like this baby's breathing
spontaneously then you would immediately
see that that for example during the
exploration of the ventilator here the
station started to breathe in so that
the ventilator is trying to adapt to the
patient but that adaptation is not
perfect and and these kind of adverse
patient ventilator interactions haven't
been systematically looked at haven't
been quantified clinicians recognize
them then they look at the ventilator
screen but we don't know how many of
them occurs for example in over twelve
hours of ventilation so I thought that
would be an interesting question to ask
for example if you look at the baby
who again like several ventilations now
these are all individual that the
patient who is not breathing still has
got some sort of irregularity because of
positioning and because of just changes
in the baby's movement or nurse handing
the baby but if the baby is building
them everything becomes much more
chaotic now so I thought that that it
would be interesting to see what's
happening during longer-term long in
terms of longer terms during mechanical
ventilation in these babies who are left
you're breathing spontaneously so
initially starting as a service
evaluation of the alarm activity of
these ventilators I've downloaded
approximately 160 days worth of
ventilator data with then how 100 Hertz
kind of sampling rate which is like one
one data point one it's a time series
data which one data point every 10
milliseconds so this leads to a large
data set when you're recording for 2 to
4 days which is the kind of typical
recording length for me so and then
these data are retrieved a CSV files so
you're looking at approximately 600 700
megabytes of data for ventilation day so
not much if you think for a whole unit
ventilation activity could be recorded
on a kind of one terabyte disk which is
not done we don't keep this a sad moment
similarly to other hospitals we never
keep these data they just gonna be there
now so mechanical ventilation is complex
if there is an interaction between the
ventilator and the patient then and what
you can see on this curve is like three
hours worth of ventilation so
approximately a million data points and
and what you see is the x-axis the
pressure now the vias this is the flow
so the pressure is responsible for the
flow now if you are if we are
ventilating an artificial lung which is
just a dummy lung doesn't have any
interaction clearly then you can kind of
make all these individual dots look very
similar to each other in terms of blood
pressure during the inspiratory arm
which is to the right side of this so if
you look at the left side panel it's a
kind of curve and the curve goes
anti-clockwise like the inspiration is
inspiratory and expiratory arm so so it
is very straight forward then the dots
are on top each other but even in a baby
who is sedated you see a complete
different picture so this is because of
ventilator patient interaction in other
words this patient had different flows
at the same pressure level because it
was interacting with the ventilator and
and if you kind of for example have a
breathing patient they become even more
complex and you can actually find
patterns in it for example and this is
the circuit area is when the people
starting to breathe and the ventilator
is sort of recognizing that breath start
and then trying to synchronize a breath
leg story so trying to create a
beneficial patient ventilator
interaction that's when the flow goes up
but the pressure not so it's done by the
patient or the ventilator so but you can
find other other I mean these are very
primitive joint plots but but you can
find probably more important differences
if you can look at individual breath
rather than through our activity of
thousands of breaths now so that came
for my perspective is to in a longer
term is to provide the cognition be
simple and quantitative indices of
ventilator patient interactions a simple
because ventilation is only one part of
our job and the condition is a very
little time to to analyze complex
patterns so it needs to be something
which is easily quantified
however to develop something like that
we need to look at individual breasts in
isolation other than creating these
graphs with thousands of press
cumulatively we need to develop needed
to be able to split the trace into
individual breaths which then would
require then it's not feasible to do it
manually you can look at an screen you
can identify one breath from the many
visually but it's not feasible to do it
on like a trace of 12 hours which has a
thousands of threads that's why I think
that's why I think I become interested
in this collaboration and my complete
computer program colleagues are going to
follow up on that and I think this is
I'm talking and then I'm going to hand
it over to to to MSI's thank you very
much can you hear that okay yeah perfect
hello everyone so my name is Ian I'm one
of the founders of the PI data London
group and the conference series and some
of people have met me before not all of
you but like the orange shirts in the
room we're volunteers here
the reason we're collaborating on this
project is that when I went to PyCon UK
last year over in Cardiff great
conference to recommend you go
I met Gustav actually I was there a day
later and everyone was saying Ian you
have to go and meet dr. Gustav Becky is
on this amazing presentation about
babies and ventilator data and he needs
help with machine learning and I reckon
you'd love it cuz you're here teaching
machine learning that's what I was doing
and so we sought each other out went to
the pub of course and then started to
have a natter about this and Gustav was
just after a non-commercial
collaboration there's no business
funding behind this to further this
there the analysis of this data so we
started talking I agreed the data looked
amazing and I wanted to play with Morga
time series data so we started always
and then the collaboration that came out
of it and so I quite like the fact that
that conference led to a collaboration
which leads to the opening of some of
the work at this conference and we keep
pushing this message of collaboration so
it doesn't have to have to be about the
work we're doing in the office of course
this all of this is about collaborating
and sharing ideas and doing interest
stuff so I fully encourage this kind of
thing so one of the aims in this project
from a data science perspective well
babies breathes very fast they take a
breath approximately once every second
so overnight that's 43,000 breaths so
those curves that you saw there are
43,000 of those every night per baby a
doctor cannot sit there and analyze all
of these to see which one's look good
and which ones look bad and yet they
need to have some high-level summary
that the baby is breathing correctly on
the ventilator machine so if we can
summarize when each breath is taking
place we can then start to apply some
statistics to analyze that data and say
which breath to look good which Express
look bad which pizzas of the the night
time or the last 10 hours a doctor
should go and check over but to do that
we have to do segmentation which we'll
cover shortly that lets us go on to do
some really interesting other areas of
analysis one which we're about to start
work on is this idea of auto-peep
auto-peep a baby breathes in their lung
inflates that has oxygen or gas in their
lungs they they breathe out viii the gas
leaves their lungs but then before it's
fully expired then the ventilator starts
pushing more air in so they haven't
fully deflated then they breathe again
they expire and then they don't fully
evacuate their lungs and so leaving this
positive pressure residual at the end of
the breathing cycle can cause tissue
damage and so that's a bad thing for the
baby so if you can start to summarize
how much air is going in and out of the
lungs on every single of those 43,000
breathing cycles you can begin to get an
idea if the lungs are properly emptying
or if they're being left partially
filled at the end of each breathing
cycle so we have to start doing the
segmentation so we can analyze that and
we're just getting to that point and
there's a whole bunch of other
interesting things that we can use to to
extend the statistical analysis of these
baby breaths once we can do the
segmentation so what does it mean to do
the segmentation so we saw a diagram
like this a bit earlier on this is a
longest time series trace you can see
these breaths are occurring once a
second so in a five second period there
are five of these breaths on the orange
side we're seeing the flow at one of the
diagrams recession earlier it's a bit
like a sine wave but compressed in time
so it goes up and then it comes
it goes back to zero that's the flow
positive flow into the baby decreasing
until they stop sucking air in and then
the negative flows they quickly push
some of the air out and then it returns
to zero as their lungs are almost empty
and then that cycle repeats and then at
the top we have the pressure in the
airway so that's the ventilator pushing
air in if there's a large contribution
and then there are smaller contributions
that's when the ventilator is not having
to do so much if he's still doing some
work they're not doing so much work so
we can see baby's breathing regularly so
we get these nice sinusoidal like waves
and then we get periods where there's a
long gap and when this long gap occurs
either the baby isn't breathing or it's
having trouble breathing and the
ventilator is waiting and it's waiting
and it's winking because oh my god and
then it starts pushing air into the baby
so the baby gets a full breath of air so
we can see these long gaps in this trace
you might just say but it's easy and
look you just look at that zero line and
whenever it starts to go up from there
that's the start of a breath and would
but it would be so easy but it turns out
that a toe can get quite messy in quite
dirty and so we wanted to put in place
the machine learning process to identify
the areas that were easier to classify
and the areas that were harder to
classify so what kind of summer is do we
want out the other side if you can
segment every one of those breaths by
that I mean if you can draw a line in
front of each of these orange beginning
of the sinusoidal wave to start break
those up then we can start to measure
things like the length of that way so
how long is that breathing cycle is that
a long breathing cycle or a short
breathing cycle if we can count many
breathing cycles and look at the length
of those that Delta's of each of those
breast lengths you can draw our
histogram so by you can do an eyeball
check in this period of time we see a
histogram that looks like this we don't
know what the right distribution is were
analyzing this but we can see a
distribution that we expect and if we
saw for example fact panels coming
outside we might say well that's a bit
odd there are lots of short breaths and
lots of long breaths why is that we
should probably go and analyze that
section and if you look at those same
deltas but plotted on a time series
chart then you can see periods where you
get the same kind of regular breathing
so that's when things are looking pretty
good over here
these nice regular breaths and then when
you get short breaths followed by long
breaths that's when the baby isn't
breathing regularly for some reason and
the ventilators wait and then the
ventilator is causing the
manually added breath and so you can see
a period of time when there's like a
non-stationarity effect coming on things
are changing so that would be a good
period to summarize for doctor the
Sailor that's a period you should go and
analyze overnight and when there were
twenty five twenty thousand breath that
look stable you haven't got to go and
analyze those but this bit you should go
and check on it now often in machine
learning projects people will go
straight into the hard core bit of the
machine learning I wanted to step back a
bit from that knowing that there are a
lot of beginners here so I wanted to
talk just a little bit about the phases
of the project and in job to take over
some of the machine learning in a moment
so the phase is behind the project the
phases that started this collaboration
so we had to get CSV files out of
gustaff these are files they're a
million rows plus so they're bigger than
will fit into Excel so they're not easy
to deal with from a non programmers
point of view but if you can put them
into pison then with pandas you can
start to look into the data and start to
do some plots of course one of the first
questions is always is my data same
that's it does this data represent what
I think the machine is telling me and
one of the the questions is well the the
machine is giving me time-stamped data
of course every time stamp is going to
be unique and incrementing because of
course you wouldn't have time series
data going backwards in time or being
word hated it turns out that the time
stamps are an issue and if ever you've
heard me talk before you know that I
always go on about gosh-darn time stamps
because they're always broken time data
is always broken in our fresh data set
to come in luckily there's a tools like
in guard or your own checks that you can
write that let you check if things like
the time stamps are monotonically
increasing and not duplicate because you
don't want multiple time stamps of data
coming out with the same add to a time
stamp so John's had to do some fixing to
sort that out but other than that the
data was good it didn't wander all over
the place it didn't have random 0
speckled into it it looked like pretty
solid data we moved on to an EDA phase
and so drawing lots of graphs looking
into the data floating
2d scatter plots plotting time series
plots summarizing sections by hand and
then asking questions what are the
ranges like do things look sense but are
we happy do we understand it as non
clinicians do we understand this data
and can we explain it back to a
clinician in a way less actually yeah
you kind of
it was a nice face then we had to get on
with building a gold standard said to do
machine learning you've got to have
annotated data we had a few annotations
from good staff at the beginning but we
didn't have lots of annotations and so
Jones talked about this
he built a tool to enable him to
annotate the data and he became a
prototype clinician sitting there
clicking away at the start of every
breast commanetating those once we had
that we could build a very simple
classifier using a citation and moving
average multiple moving averages peat
detection function which gave us a kind
of a close to where the peaks were it
wasn't super reliable but it gave us a
baseline to work from and then we could
work on with a random forest to do a
proper classifier so that was the fun
bit of the work that was the other kind
of 70% of the work and if you haven't
done this kind of project before and raw
unseen data where arts as a common thing
and technically we use Jupiter notebooks
use a lot of notebooks and get for
sharing code between the three of us
we've only met physically four times I
think four times in six months and git
er which is just like slack
collaborative chat tool when we've used
notebooks often you end up developing a
couple of cells and then copy pasting
the notebook and copy pasted my notebook
and copy pasting all those shared cells
of code and that's a bit of a bad idea
because any bug fix you're doing one
doesn't get shared amongst others so
I've developed and it is an open source
example of it to MA July's notebook I
call it's a bit like a Python module you
can do a Python set up the PI develop
and then it points back to the root of
your tree with all your notebooks in it
but then if you have a folder called
tools and you put some tool functions in
there all of your notebooks can import
from that tools folder and so you can
put with your shared code in there
whilst developing locally and if you
want an example of that does take a look
in my github at the research module
layout template and I'd love to feedback
on it we've been using it for a couple
of years on projects but I'd love
feedback from other people and also I'd
like to thank all of these open source
projects because without them we
wouldn't have been able to collaborate
to produce this piece of work
particularly the Jupiter notebooks
Beaute has become pretty useful and
we've done some nice work with it it's
all in PI since we I'm a massive Python
sweet proponent and pandas Maps lot live
and all built off of anaconda
so I think at this point Charles I hand
over to you
so when I give you here
[Music]
probably okay little big can everyone
hear me okay
yep right I won't talk at length about
this annotation tool it's something we
covered at the meetup a couple of months
ago but the the first challenge and
doing the machine learning was to have a
gold standard to work off which meant
that we had to annotate sufficient data
to train a classifier so I imitated
half-dozen traces and four of those have
annotated a good chunk of the data so
five minutes so that means about 300
breaths per trace so bouquet was good
for this because it allows you to pan
and zoom around the plots and with I PI
widgets sliders you can position
indicators where you want to mark a
timestamp for the start of a breath
so that's I'd recommend using both of
those tools these sorts of annotation
tasks so the the data that we used to
train our classifier was 75 claimed 25%
tests per patient so there's five
minutes of data and we've got a very
unbalanced data set we've got one
positive sample out of 100 so there's
one starter press in a hundred
timestamps approximately this is a
hundred Hertz data and the breathing
rate is about once per second
so having annotated data we were able to
build up a set of features that allow
the random forests that we used on this
to identify the solar breath fairly
reliably for most of the patients so
those involve indicators rate of change
cumulative volumes and so on we made
some assumptions about the ranges of
values of the classifier would see the
size of these features being similar and
we don't know quite how well this
approach will generalize but Gustav
assures me that for instance Flo is
fairly consistent between patients they
don't vary in size too much so in order
to diagnose our results so I developed
diagnostic tool and here we have the
output or one view of the output from
the classifier where we have a patient
who is heavily sedated and therefore the
breathing effort is from the ventilator
so we have here approximately 75 very
consistent breaths from the test set and
here so they've been all been overlaid
and the predicted start point for each
of these is accurate so the inhalation
portion to the left the exhalation
portion to the right of these plots and
in the subplot below we can see the
prediction probabilities from the random
forest in fact that's just for the one
of the samples that I've selected using
a widget and the Manny Lam sated
start point of that breath is also
marked at the same position in its soft
lock but it's actually obscured because
the random forest is making the
prediction
so that it's just a hint of color here
where you can see there's a very slight
nonzero prediction the sample before the
true start of breath so so this is all
good when we get on to a more
complicated data set than our classifier
struggles a little bit so this patient
is conscious and the ventilator is
contributing that there's a complex
interaction between the patient and the
ventilator and these breaths are very
inconsistent to the point where they are
difficult to manually annotate so here
the true positives are the gray lines
again but we also have false positives
in red and false negatives in blue and
we can see that this data looks pretty
messy so I've used a knife i widget
slider just to highlight one of the
false negatives here and we can see that
in this case the infant started to
breathe but the efforts poor so this is
the start of the breath that Peters out
and then the ventilator kicks in and
initiates a backup breath and then it
continues more or less normally so if we
look at the probabilities coming out of
the classifier we have our manually
annotated start point here and we have
the probabilities from the classifier in
orange and we see here that the
classifier is actually predicting the
sort of breath at this point so it's
easy to understand why that is it's a
bit more difficult to create features
that help classify make the right
choices
so the GUI tools the to two main ones
the annotation tool was written with
voce and I fight widgets and for the
diagnosis tool we used a map lot live
again with I buy widgets in order to
select the particular breath that we
wanted to highlight and that's been very
valuable to understand conditions where
the classifier is not classifying a
difficult breath correctly and there's
lots of different ways in which the
classification can fail but actually on
this data set we're still seeing an f1
score of 0.9 on our training data and
point ages on our test data so the
results aren't bad but we'd like to
improve them the eye-fi widgets team has
been very responsive so they've come
forward with new features and helped me
contribute a new feature so I'd
recommend using their tools and if you
find there's something that doesn't work
for you then it doesn't help it doesn't
hurt to ask and if you decided you
wanted to write some of these tools it'd
take you maybe two or three days to do
each one so next steps the random forest
does pretty well and we can explain why
we have an idea now what sort of
features we need to generate to get a
good result from the random forest we'd
like to do more testing to see how well
classifier has trained on one patient
cope with data from another patient and
we'd like to validate a bit more and
then move on to also peak calculations
and some other ideas that we have so
we'd be interested to know how other
people might have tackled similar issues
and if you have any experience in other
completely alternative approaches that
you think might be beneficial we love to
hear from you
so we yeah very open to feedback and
ideas and
but yeah it's like to acknowledge some
of Gustav's colleagues who've helped out
the manufacturer of the ventilator very
kindly provided good staff with the
software to enable him to download the
data there's been a lot of help from
thing some of your interns and and other
colleagues and also for financial
support from model insights and from in
dava so we've put volunteer time into
this but we've also been very grateful
for the funding that we've had there so
to get in touch I they come and speak to
us afterwards or contact us in these
various various different ways thank you
[Applause]
it's lovely this back to fit with here
that's a very good question and okay
right so you were asking what strategies
we deploy to deal with the class
imbalance issue and I honestly can't
remember how I tackle that one it's not
a major issue with this set so although
we only have one true positive in 100
samples it's it's not been a big issue
for us your thing I think correct me if
I'm wrong drugs I think we didn't take
any approach to addressing the class
imbalance the more tricky question was
identifying the right features that
cleanly identify the start of the breath
in the face of all the noise and other
weird features that occur and once
you've got the right set of features the
imbalance didn't become an issue so we
were lucky I think in that case
so the question the question has been
that how easy is for a human eye to
identify the start of the breath is that
yes so actually we did that and and I
started to do some manual attention
myself and also had a student who
actually did quite a lot of manual
annotation for me on different patients
actually so I have got another training
dataset which I can or test dataset
actually which I can then use with any
model but I had to say I've cheated a
bit because I sent the most difficult
data to them us to be as a classifier
for so this is two extreme cases here so
the one where the baby's not bleeding at
all that's very easy of course and the
other one which you just seen this is a
very very difficult so usually in
clinical care we see something in
between these two extremes and and I
think myself I can even in this one I
have it over 90% chance at least myself
95 somewhere to be very very searched
and we're the best studies but I've have
to look at more than what we looked at
here because my understanding in that
this one is based on the flow why when
I'm looking at it I'm also looking at
the pressure so I'm looking at the
pressure and the flow at the same time
and and kanishka and clinicians can
reason when is the breast are based on
starting looking at the flu and the
pressure the same time point and a
particular curve that's the answer
so the question is whether we use both
signals for the classification and at
this stage we're just using the flow
that's by far the more useful data for
this and I'd add in you're asking about
how easy it is to annotate the data it
it is difficult and it takes 10 to 20
minutes to annotate one minute of data
even with a GUI tool where you can slide
around timestamp to where you want it
and hit the button to capture that
timestamp that have been ambiguous
whatever ethics I in this data
there have been breast which even be the
pressure included I would not be able to
with high confidence say myself if this
is the very start of the bed very good
question modern ventilators okay so is
there any value of looking at
electromyogram of electromyography
diaphragm and there is a new way of
mechanical ventilation called Nava this
is called neural assist ventilators
where actually rather than the
ventilator being synchronized with the
patient inspiratory flow effort like at
the level of the endotracheal tube or
the
airway now the new ventilators actually
have got a diaphragmatic probe I can
cube which is put in the focus and then
it measures actually the diaphragmatic
activity it died in from at the EMG and
it's trying to synchronize with its
corner assess neurosis 20 liters trying
to synchronize the breath of the
ventilator with the diaphragmatic EMG
now that has that's a very new approach
and some people say this is going to be
the future some people have got this ISM
because the diaphragm does do things
which are not mediated by the brain to
start the breath and has got
diaphragmatic activity which probably in
real life don't result in ventilation so
if you really want to do it if the app
well our effort to breathe comes from
the top so the diaphragm does it but the
diaphragm has got extra signals and
therefore there is some criticism about
the never the neuroses 20 raters
at the diaphragm EMG level so that they
have got other sort of impulsive sort of
than just a bomb which to represent a
breathing effort but this is
of the futures of mechanical ventilation
yes
I think okay so the question is yes
Bradley the purpose of intensive care is
to get the patient out of intensive care
the purpose of ventilation is to take
the baby of the ventilation and that's
one reason why we're not making the baby
completely sedated because then of
course the patient is not going to come
off the ventilator before spontaneous
breaths are started now now to predict
that is very difficult and and even so
there has been clinical indicators
various people published various
clinical indicators what to predict the
patient to be able to breathe though the
tube but I usually see to the per se to
the parents is that we don't know before
we pull the tubes but but the reality is
that I think in a longer term I strongly
believe that computers are going to
ventilate better than clinicians and and
that's because they will be able to rely
on more data more indicators and more
frequent data than what conditions do so
clinicians do as experience based very
simple kind of knowledge based algorithm
of haben I'm thinking the baby is
getting ready which is very simple and
and therefore everything there is a sort
of 20% 20% into excavator failure or 10
to 20% extubation filler I think yes the
answer is yes but I don't know how to
sort of achieve that
no this is not a product this is a
interest based collaboration here with
me and and and two computer programmers
we haven't received any funding for it
we are not you know I the digger kindly
provided me this this to cable and
software to download the data but I have
got no complicated conflict of interest
I have received nothing else from digger
and and and I think we have been working
on this from enthusiasm and and just to
try to understand more about mechanical
ventilation and that's are driving me
I'm a full-time condition as well just
add on that so the intention is just to
open-source the results with some open
journal publications when we're ready
for that so it's not intended to be a
commercial product here we're solving
and a problem that's interesting from
very far so a question is about the data
set and the number of breaths we have in
it this one this is this is one minute
of data babies breathe approximately
once a second so we have approximately
60 Peaks in here in the in the flow and
in this case the ventilator is assisting
so we also have corresponding peaks in
pressure but this is a hundred Hertz
sample rate so if you want to call the
sort of a breath and so you have
approximately 100 samples to it to a
breath that that's approximately the
length of the breath and you potentially
have a hundred start points where you
don't know I don't think we have a well
if I come to here and so sample zero the
breath is initiated and by sample a
hundred the breath is all done I think
most of these are probably stopping
after around point eight point nine of a
second but the point is if we want to
segment the breaths we we need to be
able to predict which position in our
series is the start and so you know we
can be we can be off by ten milliseconds
and that matters if we're off by one off
sorry off by 100 milliseconds and that
matters if we're off by ten or twenty
that doesn't matter so much but yeah
imagine all of these join together in to
end and it gets you back to
this portion of this plot that on to the
question yep
so I thought I told you that the breath
is when when the inspiration is positive
flow the flow starts right so in a way
it would be very straightforward when
the footage positive flow starts that's
the start of the breath now the problem
is that there can be scenarios when
maybe starting a breath and then the
ventilator is still in the expiratory
phase yes I mean differ definition by
the start of the breath you know in any
individual who hasn't got two pumps just
one pump is very straightforward because
whenever the deposited flow start when
I'm starting when positive flow starts
to go in through my mouth or nose in
through my lung positive flow it invert
flow that's the start of the best I mean
you can define the breath differently
like for example than is the neuro
signal or the diaphragmatic signal for
that breath but that would require
access to those those signals directly
after a practical perspective from a
clinical perspective the best is to
define the breath at a level that you
can assess it and we have both
approximate flow sensor near the
endotracheal tube so we can measure the
flow very very carefully there and we
can identify the start of the best air
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]